the Joe Rogan experience so we're
talking about losing eyesight yes you
you actually take comfort in the fact
that your eyesight is starting to
dwindle you want to chase it at first I
was like I'm fine
then I'm 42 then it's like let's try
some once then it's 1 2 5 then it's 1 5
so now I stopped because I have so many
[ __ ] glasses some of them are ones
some of them are two fives it's like
it's like you know I mean yeah I dunno
but what I appreciate is you know where
you're at by what you're able to retain
if you fight for it and the things that
are going no matter what you do now I've
heard there's some Israeli guy who's got
this app probably from Laird got this
app and you do it you get your eyesight
back and sometimes it's about I don't
need to try to use something to hold on
to everything I want to pick the five or
seven things that I definitely want to
hold on to and I want to watch the rest
of it go in and out with the tides I
agree with that in some ways but if
there was a real thing where you could
get your eyesight back I would
definitely be on that don't think that
lasix is not real lasix but I know these
are real problems you can get it if you
have problems with your vision but we
have macular degeneration that's coming
from aged age-related macular
degeneration LASIK system really fix
that but I know people who were wearing
glasses and then got lasix and they
don't wear glasses anymore that's that's
a fact but also we never wore glasses
they get one eye to close up and one eye
for distance it's even more fun half the
eye exams I've gotten and wind up
[ __ ] me two weeks later like these
don't work yeah what about the loss of a
sense that you're accustomed to being
fine annoys you what about it yeah I
like being able to see things read
labels in particular how many of these
[ __ ] are supposed to take you know
and what's in here like how many
milligrams
what's it say also this [ __ ] but it's
also funny to go up to like a little
Lutron pad and have to go
like that to me it's just it's a gas
really interesting accept the things you
cannot change
now if someone comes in and says Joe Bob
I got it we're done come over here it's
easy or it's a supplement or do this for
two weeks or stop doing this this and
this then there's a trade-off yes
well I'm down for anything that actually
works to make your eyesight come back
but I have heard of nothing everybody
that I've heard of might be this might
be our project then because you care and
I don't so we have a nice balance
there's a guy named David Sinclair that
I talked to is a professor at Harvard
yes an American MIT where the [ __ ] is he
Harvard he's there doing some work with
people that have serious eye diseases
and serious injuries and they're
actually injecting some form of bacteria
that has been encoded with some miracle
cure for degeneration and they can
detach retinas fix things and incredible
yeah so they're working on some stuff
yeah so maybe in the future you won't
have to ISM ones and 1.5 s and yeah what
am i God fine I've alighted to greener
pastures I'm sure there's going to be
other issues and hurdles that you're
gonna go eyesight got real going on here
yeah I'm sure - I'm concerned about that
[Applause]